nothing said that they are going after
apple with their new phone too that is
for sale in the US so today we are gonna
see if they can defeat the iPhone 14
plus and based off the specs it seems
like they will but of course we're gonna
compare everything from the speakers the
displays the design performance and more
now I am a huge fan of the original
nothing phone we actually imported it
here into the states and that sucks
they're a little rip strip just messed
up I'll have to be really careful
cutting this top box but I had to pay
over 800 bucks to import the original
one and now this one even though prices
have gone up you can get it for 599
dollars in the US compared to 900 for
the 14 plus and I've got to say the
unboxing experience other than that
strip is really cool now in the Box we
do not have an adapter it's super thin
we have this cable and look at this that
looks super cool we have the clear right
here where the USBC connection comes in
feels really high quality with this cool
Sim tool but what I care about is the
phone let's pull this thing out
get this little paper cover off let's
pull it out and wow the deem that feels
a lot different compared to the nothing
phone it feels really nice that feels
okay so the back is curved
you know what this is what the new
iPhones are gonna be like nothing did it
first ahead of apple and it's kind of
harder to see because you have this
glass but the feel in the hand okay this
is better but even here just hold this
for a second okay yeah this feels great
I loved that the nothing had flat sides
like the iPhone but this is the best of
both worlds and as far as the look I
mean you can't say that looks really
really cool and unique compared to the
fingerprint magnet with this dark 14
plus now as you guys see we have the
wireless charging coils both of them
have 15 watt wireless charging but the
nothing phone can actually do reverse
wireless charging five Watts for devices
which Apple has the hardware to do it
since iPhone 12 they just don't enable
it it also has 4 700 milliamp hours
compared to
43.25 on the iPhone and with that you
can charge to 50 in 20 minutes compared
to 30. as far as the size they're almost
identical then nothing is slightly
Slimmer but slightly taller the button
layout is similar but the nothing phone
has lower buttons so it's a little bit
easier to get to and of course they have
their really cool glyphs on the side so
here's a few more they added a bunch of
extras for example you have unique call
notifications so you can see who's
calling just by the lights you have an
Essentials glyph that will stay on to
show if you have notifications you can
customize and you have a glyph timer so
if you have a timer going you'll see
that running with that you also have a
volume indicator so that is really cool
you have a charge indicator so as it's
charging it's going to show you that
level on this back one these glyphs are
so awesome and the customization is just
really sweet and we don't have that on
the iPhone now on to the front the
iPhone has face ID D whereas nothing has
a fingerprint scanner it's an optical
one and I will say this seems a little
bit low for my personal comfort of
course you'll get used to that but I
wish it was a little bit higher I do
prefer face ID but that Notch is huge
compared to that tiny cutout and I
really like that it's now centered
instead of on the side now if we look at
the bezels the nothing does have thinner
bezels than the iPhone so that is also
nice but we have a lot of other display
differences but first I've got to give a
shout out to our partner cascue who
makes awesome cases like their Cloud
Kush case which has air cushion
technology built into the frame so it's
very drop resistant while also being
incredibly comfortable to hold thanks to
the silky smooth rounded finish and
right now they are doing an iPad
giveaway running until August 8th giving
away an iPad to one of the first 100
people that enter and a second iPad at
200 people enter so use the links down
below to check out their cases and enter
the iPad giveaway today now for 5.99 I
am impressed with this screen because
it's an ltpo screen and it goes up to
120 hertz compared to just 60. so going
through here the iPhone 14 and 14 plus
always feels stuttery because I'm used
to promotion where here everything is
very smooth and you guys could see the
difference in the slow motion footage
and this also helps with battery life
because it can go all the way down to a
one Hertz to save battery when you don't
need the crazy refresh rate where this
one's stuck at 60. as far as brightness
so nothing too has some impressive specs
but I went ahead and I maxed out both of
these manually and looking at them at
least in manual brightness the iPhone
does look brighter now nothing says it
goes up to 1600 nits compared to 1200
they also list 500 and a thousand
depending on what you're doing so I'm
guessing manual is a thousand compared
to 1200 but taking it outside I was
surprised by how close the iPhone kept
up on a full white screen and then with
dark mode turned on but nothing did seem
a little bit brighter but not 1600 nits
brighter now as far as HDR I have both
these maxed out and as you guys could
see the iPhone simply looks brighter
which is weird you get the highlights
that are popping more so uh the image
processing looks a little bit better and
one thing I noticed is that if I am
moving it around and adjusting it looks
really bright right now but as soon as I
go full screen you literally notice it
dim down a lot now I went through all
the settings everything is set properly
everything is updated and I think this
might just be something they have to
tweak or they're just trying to save
power but as far as HDR video the iPhone
takes the win now one area where cheaper
Android phones struggle are the speakers
so let's go ahead and compare both of
these
[Music]
[Applause]
get me out of now
[Music]
here
okay guys that was weird the iPhone
definitely sounded better but at first
the nothing phone sighted great but as
soon as I beat dropped
um the whole phone cut down the volume
and then later cut it back up cut it
back down there's definitely something
going on with the software because at
first it didn't sound bad and then it
got a lot worse as far as volume and
sound quality I don't know if it's a bug
or what's going on but just like the
display it seems like something has to
be adjusted or changed because it
shouldn't be performing like this and
now it's time for performance I have
geekbench 6 opened up right here you
guys could see we have six gigs whereas
the nothing has eight gigs of RAM for
the base both have 128 gig of storage
and we have the a15 and the iPhone and
the Snapdragon 8 gen 1 and the nothing
phone now uh while this is running we
could talk about price a little bit some
people are upset that the price has has
gone up and yes that does suck that's
happened with other companies before but
you are getting a better chip than
before it's not you know top of the line
but it's just an older top-of-the-line
Flagship chip better build quality a lot
of other improvements making it a more
Flagship like device basically a
flagship and take a look at that of
course the iPhone beat out the nothing
we have a difference of 33 for single
core and 22 percent in case of
multi-core so apple is still ahead with
the performance even on a one-year-old
chip that came on the 13 Pros but what
about graphics performance I have 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme opened up right
here I'm going to use the unlimited mode
and let's see how they compare wow guys
this is incredibly close we have 16.8
FPS compared to 16.5 the iPhone is
beating It Out by just by a tiny bit now
I'm not sure what's gonna happen when
you know thermals kick in if you're
gaming for a while but uh Graphics wise
they are very similar now the last thing
I need to talk about are the cameras
taking a look at the back we can compare
the camera bumps personally I think that
the nothing phones camera layout looks
nicer the way the iPhone's used to look
in that vertical orientation but what is
interesting is that nothing have made a
really nice update to this phone both of
these are 50 megapixel sensors compared
to two 12 megapixels and then flipping
them around the nothing phone 2 has a 30
megapixel sensor that so that's been
upgraded compared to 12. now just
looking at these the nothing definitely
looks sharper and they said they put a
lot of effort into optimizing the
processing on here the videos got a lot
better better they added new features
and there's just so much to test so
instead of just taking a couple of shots
here what we're gonna do is tomorrow
we're gonna have an unbiased camera
comparison these things are always
incredibly fun I will take photos vedema
Angelica are going to be guessing which
one looks better and we're also going to
toss in the pixel 7 Pro to see how the
nothing compares to its biggest Android
competitor and iPhone competitor so make
sure you guys enables notifications and
you guys are subscribed because you will
not want to miss that so with that said
does the nothing phone 2 defeat the
iPhone did nothing achieve their goals
coming to the U.S market and wanting to
take on Apple and I will say in general
yes for 599 bucks you get so much value
packed into this device and it feels
premium the quality is great now the HDR
had some issues the speakers had some
issues hopefully that's fixed with
software it definitely seems with both
that gets a software issue and we'll see
how the cameras compare but for 900
bucks compared to 600
this phone is much better overall and
that is coming from somebody who loves
Apple products you guys know this
channel let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below hit that
subscribe button above so you guys don't
miss out on tomorrow's video check out
one of those this has been Max and I'll
see you in the next one
thank you